welcome to senegal country between the
atlantic ocean and the edge of the sahel
there's very little rainfall and it's
terribly hot so it's when the sun sets
that people come out to play football on
the beach and it's in places like this
that champions are made
meet thirteen-year-old jamil so and his
friends in downtown dakar there's no
space for a football pitch
and so this is how they train it's
become a trend shared on social media in
senegal
young players
showing their skills away from the pitch
trying to stand out and get attention
my dream is to become a famous football
player and wear the jersey of the
national team like money and score a lot
of goals for the national team
one of the top scorers in the english
premier league during his time with
liverpool bayern munich's new signing is
senegal's hero
this is where mane learned to play in
the village of bambali in southern
senegal in june he came back to play an
exhibition match with former players of
the national team
musang jai was part of the squad that
beat france reaching the quarterfinal of
the 2002 world cup
the fact that we don't have green
football pitchers is actually an
advantage because when you play in the
sand you learn a lot of technique like
how to control the ball to dribble and
make accurate passes it makes us better
players
senegal are the reigning african
champions the fans are hoping qatar is
the place where senegal make history
and become
the first
african team to reach
a world cup final
nicholas hawk al jazeera dakar